tout l'aspect du stockage et de la
gestion des réseaux va devenir de plus
en plus important et c'est là où on peut
trouver
je voudrais une belle complémentarité ou
hydro québec connaît bien les réseaux
est en train de développer une
technologie de batterie à la fine pointe
avec nous et éric martel directeur on
parle de complémentarité grosses
transactions quand même pour hydro
québec l'une des plus importantes de
l'histoire c'est une transaction
importante c'est probablement peut-être
même notre plus grosse transaction de
notre histoire
dans le fond ce qu annonce aujourd'hui
c'est la création d'un joueur québécois
dans l'énergie renouvelable qui va
rayonner sur la scène internationale
alors vous le savez il ya beaucoup de
compétition il ya un potentiel énorme en
croissance des énergies renouvelables
ici je parle surtout de du solaire de
l'éolien et aussi de la petite idée
roues et dans le ciel innergex oeuvre
déjà et peut-être potentiellement depuis
randy d'euros que nous réclamons 9 mai
la complémentarité hissel est
intéressante parce que nous on off comme
vous savez des recherches en batterie
alors il ya des systèmes de stockage de
batteries confort met à contribution
dans les projets qu'on va faire ensemble
il ya aussi toute la connaissance
évidemment dû résoudre balancer des
réseaux de simuler des réseaux que
hydro-québec aussi bon pour mettre à
contribution
évidemment notre capacité financière
alors les deux ensemble ça fait qu'on
devient un joueur québécois extrêmement
compétitif sur la scène internationale
mais vous avez déjà de l'expertisé en
interne
monsieur martel vous avez par exemple
des projets
soler la varenne la prairie est
différent pourquoi passer par innergex
pour donner de l'élan à ce type de
projet de nouvelles énergies
c'est une bonne question on n'a pas nous
construit de parcs solaires et mis en
service de parcs solaires ont fait de
l'expérimental seulement présentement
pour le québec
perçue innergex qui eux déjà en présence
quand même assez importante vous savez
qu'ils ont à peu près le tiers de leur
chiffre d'affaires au québec mais quand
même
le reste de leur chiffre d'affaires et
en europe aux états unis et aussi en
amérique du sud et la coïncidence ces
sites est bonne parce que c'était les
mêmes pays sur lesquels nous travaillons
alors c'est sans corde il y avait de la
contre complémentarité de ce côté là
c'est encore mon temps quand même que
vous avez investi est ce que ça va être
payant comment vous allez partager les
profits ou peut-être les pertes dans
certains projets écoutez nous on va être
très rigoureux vous savez on a eu une
approche disciplinée j'annonce et déjà
il ya quelques années qu'on travaillait
sur nos exportations ce qui avance très
bien mais qu'on travaillait aussi sur
des acquisitions à l'international de
revenir dans font parce qu'on avait déjà
fait ça alors on a souhaité ça mais on
est très discipliné rigoureux dans notre
approche on a eu des occasions on aurait
pu faire des transactions monde et
laisser passer ce qui est important pour
moi c'est de créer de la valeur pour les
québécois vous savez hydro-québec action
québécois de dividende no nos revenus
nos profits en fait on retourne à la dhr
actionnaires et on en bénéficie tous
alors nous on va faire des transactions
qui vont être profitable dont on est pas
mal certain que ça va être un succès une
croissance énorme dans ce marché là et
on va regarder ce projet par projet vous
savez déjà dit je choisir à la pièce
mais il donne l on prend 20 % dans
innergex 19% pour être précis mais on
aura peut-être l'opportunité de croire
ça jusqu'à un certain montant
mais aussi on veut regarder les projets
pièce à la pièce à l'audi projet sur
lequel on va pouvoir contribuer avec nos
connaissances
on va pouvoir travailler ensemble et
aller de l'avant vous parliez d'un
retour à l'international est ce que ce
sera la façon de faire d'hydro-québec de
s'allier avec d'autres entreprises pour
reconquérir les marchés internationaux
et puis il ya encore un potentiel de
croissance au québec pour hydro québec
mais comme on est con on occupe déjà
beaucoup d espaces il est moins grand
comme les énergies renouvelables nous on
est déjà dans une situation privilégiée
avec
l'électricité mais vous savez une course
à l'éolien et au solaire dans les autres
pays on veut participer à ça on ajoute à
la complémentarité dans nos
connaissances de base et on peut
évidemment faire croître notre
organisation l'intention ici c'est de
faire plus de profits pour hydro québec
à l'international
ramener cet argent là chez nous et
évidemment faire profiter les québécois
de ses profits lorsque vous parlez de
faire plus de profit vous avez fixé un
objectif quand même ambitieux doubler
les revenus d'ici 2030 c'est pas
seulement avec l'énergique ce que vous
allez bien donc ça sert ça restera sur
les marchés internationaux qu'on va y
arriver
effectivement bio aussi la croissance au
québec et du potentiel de croissance au
québec vous savez on travaille
présentement sur attirer les centres de
données à titre d'exemple c'est un
potentiel de croissance pour nous on
parle de serre
on parle de plusieurs autres projets
mais évidemment à l'international y un
potentiel énorme alors innergex avait
déjà un peu pied dans ce milieu là au
niveau des énergies renouvelables et on
va contribuer à les aider à aller
chercher une plus grosse part de marché
par scannant un code du québec on est
toujours en situation surplus la
d'énergie on cherche à écouler ses
surplus là c'est pas avec l'énergie est
ce que vous allez débouchés non c'est
pas ça qui va nous aider vous à votre
question est très pertinente d'ailleurs
d'en augmenter nos profits dans l'est
dans les prochaines années
il va y avoir plusieurs éléments bon il
ya la croissance internationale qu'on
parle il y aussi les exportations qui
sont importantes
vous savez on travaille sur un très très
important contrat pour nous pour écouler
nos surplus j'ai toujours dit qu'on
avait de l'espace pour à peu près deux
gros contrats et demi on est signée avec
le nouveau brunswick une entendre un
mois sur jusqu'en 2040 alors ça
s'adresse la demi qu'on en avait besoin
comme vous le savez on travaille très
très fort ça avance bien avec le
massachusetts nord est où on eu
plusieurs il ya presque 10 12 permis au
total allé chercher des fonds réalise
fois ça on en a environ 1 seulement
qu'elle pas environ exactement 1 qui
nous restent aux mains et de haut niveau
fédéral alors une fois qu'on a ça on a
déjà tous les permis du côté du
massachusetts on va pouvoir commencer
est passé de l'avant
au niveau de la construction de la ligne
new york aussi c'est d'ailleurs ici
oui effectivement et le maire je crois
devrait réitérer dans les prochains
jours son désir de signer avec nous un
contrat d'ici la fin 2020 alors on a nos
équipes sont déjà actives la bosse ça
travaille fort on négocie pour les
québécois et puis on veut s'assurer de
le signer ce contrat là aussi parce que
ça va nous faire les deux contre
l'ennemi qu'on avait besoin pour écouler
nos surplus donc on est en situation de
surplus on mise sur les énergies
renouvelables les nouvelles énergies si
vous voulez est ce que le potentiel de
croissance est encore plus fort ce côté
là parce que si on regarde dans le monde
depuis une dizaine d'années bloomberg
ressortait des chiffres disait 2600
milliards de dollars d'investissement
pour le solaire l'éolien le solaire en
particulier où il y avait des hausses de
capacités incroyables faut pas passer à
côté c'est ça faut pas passer à côté
c'est exactement ça c'est un marché
gigantesque qui est disponible sur la
planète pour donner de l'espace à vie le
solaire et l'éolien ou
l'hydroélectricité quand c'est possible
vous remplacez plusieurs combustibles
fossiles qu'on utilise aujourd'hui pour
faire de l'électricité ou de chauffage
alors pour nous hydro québec c'est une
façon avec la transaction qu'on annonce
aujourd'hui de rentrer dans ce marché là
à l'extérieur du québec puis de prendre
une place significative
en terminant je vous entendre monsieur
martel surtout l'aspect consommateurs
aux clients de la chose vous avez une
remise qui s'en vient il était temps de
commencer déjà remettre l'on emprunté
pour qu'ils demandent de faire cela donc
même si c'est contester ça va de l'avant
à quel moment les les consommateurs ou
les clients peuvent voir ce solaire
d'ici d'ici la fin mars on va voir la
grande grande majorité des clients qui
vont avoir reçu un crédit sur leur
facture au total on va rembourser 535
millions de dollars alors on y paie the
rule of health et déjà commencé alors il
ya des clients qui vont commencer à voir
apparaître sur leur facture dans les
prochains jours monsieur martel merci
beaucoup merci au top 14